good morning Millennials good morning
everyone good morning Heather hi welcome
back to the morning toast I am thrilled
to be here I am thrilled that you're
here the toasters are thrilled that
you're here the toasters have been like
Loki harassing you for months
trying to get you here they have it's
like I was working behind the scenes
trying to get you here and that was just
lost on them right but everyone's happy
because today you are here and we are
going to spill the tea we're gonna spell
the team we're gonna tell you the news
that's lips you don't really need to
know it but you know it could be helpful
you never know what you're gonna talk
about at dinner tonight good point um
and just quiz you just on everything
that's gone on since last time I saw you
and it's been two months exactly and I
know that because last time you were
here I was on my period today I'm on my
period I'm about to start look at us
just sinking our cycles and last time I
like you told me you were about to start
yeah so I'm glad we're both staying
regular oh yes we are staying regular my
breasts are engorged so that's where
we're at today happy Thursday
I realize that it was like I don't know
I'm gonna say that but you know what it
felt right no I and I'm glad we should
be really like more expressive and open
about our cycles right now I'm reading a
book called the woman code right now and
it's like don't be ashamed of your bear
the new big thing is like parrots like
trying to be more I don't need to be so
open about it there are some things that
should remain a mystery but like it Amy
Schumer does like a bit in her stand-up
way and like the way you walk to the
bathroom with a tampon it's like hiding
it like that shameful thing and you know
right okay I just I've literally I'm
always kind of bloated and like and I'm
always hungry all the time so Jeff my
boyfriend could never pick up on it he's
like you know what I mean like you know
you eat extra when you're PMSing but
yeah just eat that way all the time so
he never picks up on it and I'm just
kind of like always manic you know right
so he never knows that's great yeah
there's no like fluctuations right if
you're just nuts 24/7 you're always on
your period so you know living my truth
yes well we appreciate it we'd love your
truth and we're so happy to have you
here I'm so glad to be back I know it
was like two months in the making but I
had so much fun and I just felt like we
really vibed last time and they were
just getting into the gossip
we're what has happened in the last two
months what have you been up to are you
moving to New York I am moving to New
York probably at the beginning of next
year I was gonna move right before the
holidays but then I'm going to like
Europe for vacation so it's like this is
stupid I'm not gonna move into an
apartment and then you know right and
yet and pay for the apartment and then
not live in the exactly well
Jeff's paying for the apartment because
I'm an unemployed actor so you know got
to work that in couple hand jobs at a
time but yes so I think we're gonna wait
till the new year so you know when it's
like January 5th and it's freezing and
there's no apartments left in the city
that's what I'll be moving I feel like
it's a bad time to move physically
because it's cold and like you have to
stand outside and hold a couch right but
I feel like not how many people move
during that time so there's actually
pretty good availability well you can
get a good deal on an apartment but
there's like three literally three
apartments in the city because nobody
wants to move so there's like three
available but you know me see Jeff you
know all men think they're good
negotiators but at the end of the day
like we're actually the ones who get the
job done like if you ever want to like
buy or sell a house you always take a
woman you know I mean the man may be
writing the check well it's 2018 please
we're making our own money yes but my
mom always said like the woman is the
one who picks out the house so I'm the
one who's gonna go in there and like
negotiate with the landlord and like
cause a scene yeah I mean yeah a
professional scene but still a scene
true I'm actually the worst negotiator
of all time really yeah and my fiance
Zack is really good at it right he's
almost like too good at it like I feel
like sometimes it's like insulting right
like how you negotiate mm-hmm could be
insulting to someone so I literally an
ago she ation that's how bad I am at it
like I have to like walk away and
pretend like I don't know these people
Oh could you get like sweaty and look at
this I get so nervous see I thrive
because I can't okay so I've been in a
relationship for so long I don't know if
I can actually flirt you don't I mean
but you got to add like a little
flirting element into it even if it's a
woman you know you could just kind of
like it's a sales technique you got to
speak at their level so if they're kind
of soft you got to get down here and
just kind of say you know so the
apartment you said was what was it 4500
how about we signed a two-year lease for
4,000 and call it a day yeah you got a
you got to match their tone yeah and you
have to it has to be realistic like you
can't be like oh can we do 3,500 for no
reason but like you're giving them
something with two years right that I
could
it was still that's something I need to
get better at but slowly but surely I
used to be like the worst just like
conversation less I couldn't even like
try and move my flight on the phone with
Delta like it would give me anxiety
oh I'm the queen of changing flights oh
my god you just spritz him to start
weeping and you're like my uncle he lost
the leg like if you just talk about like
missing limbs people will shut down like
literally you know I'm dealt I'm like
loyal to Delta forever so like nobody
called out don't let them know that I've
like glide to change them flights we all
have okay but literally I'll just cause
a scene and it's always like an aunt or
an uncle who has like no limbs laughs
you know you just got to go if you go so
over-the-top they panic yeah I know it's
like Tammy on the phone and she's like
honey we're going we're gonna change it
and they waived the fee and everything
well one time I need to move a flight
for real cause like there was a there
was a death and it just messed with my
plans and they wanted the death
certificate oh they do that
yeah yeah yeah I didn't even know how to
get one like I I wasn't lying right and
I find that worse I just ate the costume
with like of course and then it was like
two hundred dollar change fee and then
it was like six hundred dollars because
you had to leave like the next morning
yeah yes you could have bought a
round-trip ticket
like literally Bora Bora yeah for
cheaper yeah so if you say there's a
death you actually have to show a death
certificate but if you just say that
like oh yeah uncle Larry got hit by a
bus next thing you know like there's
blood everywhere they don't question it
you don't mean they don't want to see
pictures no they don't want to see
pictures no hell no they do not want to
see pictures yeah and then and you just
pretend like you're hyperventilating on
the phone can you tell I'm a dramatic
actress oh yeah you're but you're an
actor so that's like easier for you yes
I don't have an acting bone in my body
because if I did I would be on the
Hallmark Channel this season oh good for
you have you ever auditioned for a
hallmark movie I haven't but I feel like
I would really thrive in a melodrama so
it's so funny that you guys are obsessed
with Blue Bloods because I am actively
trying to get on Blue Bloods and I know
some people there and I'm like literally
like hi when will you put me on Blue
Bloods so that's my goal and my future
mother-in-law
that's Acker favorite show and Jeff said
the only way for her to ever like me or
respect me is like to get on Blue Bloods
so that's what I'm working on but that's
like you could do it I could do it goal
right and the thing is comedians can
always do dramatic but dramatic actors
can't always be funny so I'm like I'm
ready I'm ready for like a real dramatic
role
I'll play a hooker I'll play a dead body
that then like comes back to life
you know I'll play like an attorney you
know I think anything a prosecutor I'm
here I'm ready you audition for a law
and order no but I that's such a New
York thing and I've been out of the New
York scene for a while but as a New York
actor every single person New York's
behind in law and order
there are so many there are so many
episodes there's so many seasons there's
so many parts hmm it's like and then if
you hear someone who watches old
episodes of Law & Order you really see
every actor actress to ever ever like
Willy Rhinehart's on Law & Order right
right right right yeah and you play
everything yeah yeah I would love to be
on Law & Order media what I think I'm
not much of an actress but I can
definitely play a dead body cuz that's
my strong suit it was like Ozark shoots
in Atlanta one of my favorite shows with
Jason Bateman and literally I would call
my agent be like hi it's all about meth
heads in the Ozarks in Missouri I can
play a method like just I'll take the
lashes off you know what I mean like I
can go from scary to like glam real
quick and back the other back the other
way yeah well speaking of shows that
film in Atlanta this was something I was
gonna wait to talk to you about but you
posted a story to Instagram that just
has like everyone shook especially the
toasters right you are on a flight from
New York to Atlanta yes sitting next to
like two girls yes like in great actor
were they both actresses or I did not
know who the girl sitting next to me was
I just knew the actress was okay so her
friend they were talking as if they were
both on the show but I didn't I don't I
didn't recognize her okay so at least
one of them is an actress on a show
that's filming in Atlanta yes that to be
a success so you say yes and she was
talking [ __ ] about the lead actress of
the show yes she was saying that we
would never be friends in real life yes
and opened up her Instagram and was
playing her Instagram very loudly and
kind of like making fun of her here was
the thing okay I am 31 years old and I'd
like to say that I really good plain
etiquette and this girl clearly wanted
to stir the pot she wanted people to
hear what she was saying because she was
speaking so loudly about the most
outrageous egregious things you would
ever speak about in public it was insane
like he got to the point I was listening
to my podcast and I just pretended like
I had
listening but I wasn't and I was just
losing to the crazy [ __ ] that they were
saying it was like two spoiled little
brats on a plane
pulling in their shirt Julie they were
hitting the bait and then blowing in
their shirts I and at one point like the
stewardess was walking towards us and I
was like if she sees I'm dueling I will
legit be like it's them they're smoking
on an airplane that's like so illegal so
illegal Wow did you hear that the jewel
Factory was rated so the FDA has like is
really on Jools case because teenagers
are smoking jewels right and they feel
as though jewels jewel is marketing
towards teens when they shouldn't be
right so they went to the headquarters
seized marketing documents over a
thousand documents to see if like they
really are intentionally targeting teens
of course they are yeah how do you feel
about jewel in general okay Wow where do
I begin with the jewels here's the thing
there's a thing called popcorn lung that
nobody wants to talk about but it's
actually from all these vapes because
you know like I like to date you know
plants that make you relax do you know
what I mean I don't know if I can like
legally say what I'd like to date you
know yeah but it's so and my doctor was
like hey just a heads up I'm glad use
that to relax at night but because it
has I guess is it because it has water
in it basically those things can cause
bacteria to grow in your lungs and then
it pops like popcorn
so vaping is not necessarily that much
better for you than smoking cigarettes
because you're just gonna get popcorn
lung instead of black lung exactly but
still [ __ ] up lung yes either way your
lungs are done so is one worse than the
other I don't know I mean actually my
sister who's like a real stress out
attorney all of her friends are smoking
the jewels and she's like 34 cuz she's
trying to quit smoking cigs I know it's
like so gross but when you're an
attorney that's just like what you do
you know so she's on the jewel and I'm
like Ashlee live your truth she's like
Heather if the 14 year old kids are
doing it like half of her clients or
Julianne she's like I got to get on that
jewel game but she's literally doing it
to try and wean off okay six so here's
the thing I was coming out of a club in
the Hamptons which I would I didn't even
know that there were clubs in the
Hamptons and
we had dinner there really early and
then we were walking out at like 10:30
and there was like 600 kids we were like
you know not even like 20 and every
single kid out there was Julianne I
literally went up to one of the kids and
I was like can you explain what's
happening and oh yeah you have to have a
jewel like you don't you do not go out
but but like those kids are like 18 20
or whatever they look down on kids who
smoke cigarettes so they think they're
superior there's like a hierarchy full
hierarchy that's so wild also what's
wild to me about Julian I feel like
people smoking when they're out and
drinking isn't like a new thing a lot of
people like smoke when they're drunk but
have never touched a cigarette sober you
know like Julian like my sister Margot
who's at MIT was like people duel in the
library they charge it in their computer
and then take it out and smoke it like
thankfully it's going everywhere now
listen I of course used to get drunk and
then smoke cigs outside the bar in
college everyone did that right you know
that makes us feel so old like oh god I
loved like a what was it the natives the
spirit cigarettes you know with the
Native American headdress on the front
yes supposed to be like have love
American spirit American spirit Scott
it's been so long somehow does it I kind
of want a cigarettes to do like we're
gonna break yeah we're gonna need to
take a smoke break and I want to like
sit and just like you know crack open a
glass of Cabernet and just have a moment
that's amazing yeah well anyways now
people are taking that to the library
which is like really wild anyways I just
wanted your take on Jules so these girls
are drooling on the plane oh yeah so
they're dueling on the plane they're
talking [ __ ] about everything I was just
so flabbergasted at one point I even
thought about saying like hey honey just
heads up like I know you don't you don't
want to be saying all this stuff on the
airplane literally got to the point
where then she started talking about
like this crazy sexual stuff the girl
sitting in front of us it was a sassy
black girl I was obsessed with literally
turned around and was like can you not
and the two girls like I can't believe
she's like trying to tell us to be quiet
but it was so it was obnoxious I mean
they were speaking at a level like it's
18 went on the plane write you down here
like a level eight right mm-hmm interest
and they were both dressed like homeless
people well that's just so entertaining
better than a podcast yes better than a
podcast and I personally me and the
toasters have been trying to figure out
who it is and I thought
is really onto something my message to
you I thought they were talking about
Maude Apatow no and I feel like she's
such an angel no yeah but that they were
like being mean about her and she's lead
on the show and she is filming a new
show that's gonna be on HBO that's based
off it is really serious so she could be
a success and there are some like
thirsty lower to your actresses right
that would have fit the bill but then he
said at that time no it wasn't her and I
feel like I feel like her parents would
keep her humble yeah well seemed like
the lead actress that they're talking
about seems very kind she's very kind
and she's lovely and everyone knows her
that's all again and it's filming in
Atlanta and it hasn't premiered yet but
you think it's gonna be a good big
success mm-hmm yes okay and it's I mean
it's not dynasty cuz that or any sort of
thing my managers like if you go on
blast and blast this girl your careers
over so I told everybody remind me any
year like to the date and maybe all when
the show comes out I'll be like spill
the tea like anonymously but you guys
can't tell anybody they're like I told
you um but yeah she is she's got you
know famous parents I don't know if
they're Scientologists either and you
know I'm terrified of that right oh
that's a whole another that's a whole
another thing okay what don't you so
much today I've been so dehydrated well
that's good is it though it is drinking
water is great yeah this coffee's AB
also metal straw metal straw and some
lovely fans sent this to me it says the
Italian stallions gal they made me a
time raved yes it's engraved also I
noticed in the bathroom this whole
building is going anti-plastic yes it is
and I see you're rolling in with your
iby OS I bring my own straws yeah well
they're throwing they're gonna throw
shade at you in the break room because
you've got plastic you've got a plastic
cup I mean a paper cup it's a paper cup
and the longer that it sits here like it
just integrates and so this cup isn't
really harmful the cap is probably
harmful I'm sure I'll take those away
soon I mean I have two plastic things
but this is what I do afterwards I set
them on fire no actually you're not
supposed to do that like chemicals into
the you know atmosphere no I just take
scissors and I cut this up and then I
put it in a box and then later I'll make
a necklace I ain't burying it and I
didn't know you can't buried in sand cuz
then the plastic goes into the earth
okay I just make jewelry I'm gonna start
making jewelry out of all my closet cups
that's so cute
we met this woman at camp toast who was
she was working the coffee bar and she
said her jeans were made out of recycled
plastic that's a thing yeah I think H&M
even does they were in Liz Claiborne she
said look it up and they're made out of
old plastic great very cool very cool
anyways I appreciate your commitment to
the metal star life and I understand why
you've done it and so what is what
happens to this straw when you get up
from the chair when I get up from the
chair I'll go and I'll just rinse it off
and I'll put it back in my bag and I
have like a cute little um brush that I
can clean it out with like a lot of this
and then I just use it at my next drink
okay so you clean it out and you dry it
off yes and I'm not even kidding you
people at Starbucks have thanked me
though the workers have been like I'm
like oh no I don't need a straw be like
thank you thank you so much I like
you're welcome I feel like they're
thanking you for just like being there
all the time and and like shining a
positive light on them I'm really trying
to get back to the box you know and I'm
really trying the opposite but I'm glad
that we're both so resolved in our
efforts okay without further ado here
are the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast okay
first story is just something that's
been in the works for a while and really
hits home for me because I'm Kim
Kardashian is suing her former body card
for six million dollars by the insurance
company because of the Paris thing yes
Pascal peskow another fight hire a
bodyguard named Pascal in the first
place he wouldn't hire bodyguard that
looks like that oh my god wait a minute
do you like what's so crazy about sure
he's like he was like becoming famous
for being Kim's bodyguard Lee was in the
background of pictures when that guy who
was like a prankster in Paris like
attacked her yes he took him down that
picture went viral right only viral
enough till the next day when she got
robbed and not sort of superseded the
prankster but it's been two years since
Kim Kardashian was robbed at gunpoint in
Paris and her former security guard
Pascal do the air is now being sued do
the air who left Kardashian alone in her
apartment to guard her sisters at a
nightclub the night of the robbery and
protect security the company he worked
are the targets of a 6.1 million dollar
lawsuit by insurance company AIG reports
TMZ the 6.1 million dollars is the
amount AIG paid to Kardashian for the
stolen jewels including a massive
diamond ring the suit place is much of
the blame for the robbery under the air
citing security breaches at the hotel
that he failed to correct AIG also
claims do the air pale to point out
several problems including in an
insecure front gate of the hotel and a
malfunctioning intercom system on the
night of the robbery gunman posing as
cops gagged and tied up the star she was
left in her bath bathtub as they ran off
with her jewelry at least 17 people have
been arrested in connection to the
jewelry heist and shortly after the
robbery Dubey air was sacked by the
Kardashian family okay I have two
questions
it's Pascal Italian or French he looks
like he's from New Jersey Shore but I
feel like Pascal is a French name yeah I
don't think he's Italian he like I feel
perhaps that he's French or even like
Eastern European Romanian ocean yes
situation a Romanian situation a
Romanian situation okay here's that's
the first thing that's the first mistake
she did also so she's suing him but
she's not necessary saying that he was
to blame the insurance company is suing
him because they were the ones that had
to pay right her on the night insurance
is such [ __ ] right let me just say
that get on my soapbox and say I don't
understand how it works I don't
understand what it covers I don't
understand insurance also I once saw the
funniest mean that was like worst case
scenario with insurance you've just lost
a ton of money exact like you're paying
insurance hoping that you never need to
get insurance but then when I need to be
covered they're always like oh yeah you
forgot to get like comprehensive
coverage right your plan doesn't cover
this yes and I'm like okay I have no
legs left and they're like cool you
didn't check the box for leg insurance
you're like what the [ __ ] Cheryl you're
my agent and you led me astray so it's
like all those payments you've been
paying all those years what did they go
towards like a nice home for Cheryl but
what about Cheryl's literally an
Adirondacks just like thriving you know
what I mean she's on a speedboat do they
have lakes in the Adirondacks I've never
been there I feel like there's been for
sure a man-made yeah she's literally on
a boat like just vibing listening to
Kenny Chesney drinking you know like
Mike's Hard Lemonade all day well I'm
over here with no legs bleeding out and
then I got a call Delta and she
you're gonna be that's where I'm at oh I
feel you okay I get that the inch the
insurance company is always gonna try
and sue somebody it's like even when you
get an offender bender you know right
they try and sue like State Farm Sue's
Allstate whatever I'm like just Duke it
out and I just feel for Pascal because I
feel like at the time he kind of
shouldered a lot of the blame but even
Kim said like it wasn't past Gauss fault
and I just I feel like none of them
really knew the level that they were at
right you know he was like bodyguarding
her like he bodyguards any celebrity
like he is Fergie's bodyguard now like
Fergie like he's a Fergie level
bodyguard why don't they all have their
own bodyguards well now that you after
this now they're like full mossad I'm in
there and there are no there will be no
breaches hopefully did they what
happened
criminally like did they figure out who
it was did they catch those guys yes so
70 people were arrested and then like 70
17 oh and then came like had to go and
testify it's right and there was a
really scary episode yeah very sad
that's like we were talking about our
toast movie of the week which was room
last week have you seen it is that with
real arson and Jacob Tremblay
yeah I've seen bits of it but I just I
can't like being abducted honestly is
like one of my Meshuga it is my biggest
fear and I thought I was you know old
enough now to watch the film and it was
okay now I find myself like every night
before I go to sleep like just thinking
about room and the story that it's based
off of which is so much worse than that
then the movie I've was that one of my
favorite steak houses in Atlanta and I
swear to God I thought a woman was being
trafficked and I literally went up to
her in the bathroom I was like ma'am are
you okay and she was like yeah I'm fine
she just had a creepy boyfriend
oh really thought I was like she looked
kind of brushing and young and I was
like are you okay like I just want to
check I followed her to the bathroom
like a [ __ ] creep and kid for you
yeah and she was like if you see
something say something cuz I don't know
like I carry myself I have broad
shoulders and I don't think anybody
would like try and pick me up in fact
when I studied abroad in Italy when I
was in college like my sister's really
little and she did the same program as
me and my dad was so concerned he like
put a tracker on her phone all these
things and I was like dad weren't you
concerned about me and he was like
Heather it would take at least 7 French
2 dudes to throw your ass in the back of
a van we're 17 or 17 that came squad
yeah so he was not worried about me
being taken because I'm
denser and I was like that's 1/8 rude
and - I guess I just like keep my eyes
and ears open for other smaller people
yes you know let me appreciate the work
that you do I will keep an eye on you I
don't have on behalf of small
defenseless people very weak people just
call me Pascal I like that I wanted
chinstrap this guy you need a google him
if you can't see him he has a chin strap
and then like a little soul patch here
just like I just saw thing ya know he
was like iconic in the Kardashian
community and sang now he's being blamed
for everything and I don't think it's
his fault it's not not his fault but
like Kim told him to go to the club with
her sisters like what is he gonna do not
listen to Kim she's a boss yeah and I
mean you know sometimes scary things
have to happen for us to learn and grow
right but it really is still so crazy
that not happened to Kim like this like
the story of Kim's robbery is like a
story that we'll be telling our children
you know absolutely like it was a cold
dr. embers October night Kanye West was
performing at the governor's not
Governors Ball I'm the one up here
what's that festival called um Randall's
Island Randall's Island no the other one
yeah the Mike festival yes that's right
that he was performing at Greek fest in
Queens and it's turn a story a Boulevard
yes he was you know eating spa Nico
Peter baklava and do an easy [ __ ] so
also known as The Meadows when the set
was abruptly cut short yes he had to go
cut to came in Paris in a bathtub tied
up yes wild wild and honestly that's why
she only carries that little gold band
and you know what like I'm about to get
engaged and yes I deserve eight carats
after eight years but I'm also like
honestly dated to eight we're a tiny
band like you could clubbed over the
head outside Whole Foods you don't know
not even like I'd rather get clubbed
over the head than what my worse here is
which is getting my finger chopped off
then never go to Naples
because that's what they do in Italy oh
my god I thank Florida Naples Florida is
Savage - yeah Florida is Savage no
offense I marry Georgia and so I can
talk [ __ ] about Florida all day long
that's right very literally above it I'm
literally above it but when I meet
people from Florida okay I will admit I
automatically go oh like I kind of you
know take a step back I make your
psychos my walls go up I walls go up and
then when people tell me they're from
inland Florida I'm like why why would
you move to Florida at all states and
then live two hours from the beach right
I get it if you have a farm there's
actually some like cool farms down there
but like come on yeah you got a white
rapper Florida no but they know like you
know even if you're a good person from
Florida like that you are aware that
there are people in your state that are
just really [ __ ] it up for you guys
and it's it's such a beautiful state it
is so sunshine see it's the sunshine and
orange state and I think this is why I
really have a chip on my shoulder about
Florida is because being a southerner
people are always like Oh Georgia a
bunch of rednecks or Alabama bunch of
rednecks I'm like no no you've never met
a redneck - you met a Florida redneck
cuz they're left out of their mind
they're like scary white people who like
wrestle alligators that's how it's fab
salts they're more wild than like people
from Louisiana so I just feel like you
want to see world country real you know
they're all Flocka remember that flock
is essentially bath salts okay yes and
yes
remember that guy was like running
through the streets naked and he liked a
lady's face yes might have been his
parents my guess what happened in
Florida of course it did yeah this next
story is just speaking to me and I want
to get your take on it
okay cuz Kanye West goes out ran during
an arts school visit saying leave Elon
Musk the [ __ ] alone
Kanye West gave an impromptu lessons to
students at a Michigan Art School
jumping on a table and telling kids to
quote leave Elon Musk the [ __ ] alone
quote Elon Musk I don't give a [ __ ]
who's over at his house leave that man
the [ __ ] alone the 41 year old rapper
ranted during his Tuesday visit to
Detroit's College of Creative Studies
it's unclear what prompted the outburst
which was captured on video and posted
to Twitter by a student named Josh he
might have been referring to the
comments made by Azealia Banks in August
about the CEO banks is stirring the pot
she really isn't the fact that like she
has had a hand in like taking down Elon
Musk and I don't feel good about it
honestly I don't
Azealia I watched the whole Twitter
thing when the thing with Grimes is
coming out but I was just like I've been
asked to threesomes before
I declined cuz that's like not my that's
not I'm brand for me I mean right um but
but you don't knock someone's yums thank
you I couldn't have said it better
myself I don't look someone's young
exactly how do you feel about young
because people like I I think he's a
genius I think we're I think he's trying
to send us a message just like Britney
has been trying to send us a message I
will sent you a like to our podcast with
Joe Rogan and him and honestly he talks
about AI stuff like we don't realize
that the robots are coming for us so if
you guys want to like get onto him
because he's like doing crack for like
smoking too much weed or doing acid and
trying to have a threesome you need to
listen
the robots are going to take over and
he's trying to warn us no I'm totally
teen or none and it's like now it's like
think like being teeny on is like
controversial but I'm standing by him he
has yet to do anything that would like
that negates all of the positive change
that he's bringing to the world thank
you you know and if you know what's
coming like a robot war war right like
that could drive you a little crazy I
think even that could keep you up at
night room style like my room is Elon
Musk's robot war like he's got a lot on
his mind he knows things that we don't
know it's like okay obviously we're in a
weird political climate but why would
you ever want to be president because
you know when you become president they
sit you down in a room and they're like
aliens are real this is what's happening
you join in the Illuminati you have to
like give them your blood like the whole
thing
I don't ignorant is bliss to me
sometimes I like to be awake and woke
but I also like to like chill right and
it's like if there's a robot war
hopefully it's not for I don't know 50
years and hopefully like he's not around
for it you know and then it's not my
problem honestly this is gonna sound
weird
I think someone's talking about me right
now my ears are so really the toasters
maybe someone's like watching with their
friend Network and they're like oh my
god Heather I love her jacket like this
look is so fall chic thank you Zara and
morning show host special thank you but
it's like New York so I still have my
kicks on right because you've got places
to go I have a lot of walking at Lord &
Taylor to do I'm excited for you thank
you
speaking of walking I'm actually gonna
jump around stories wise cuz that's just
I love a good segue yes speaking of
walking Fitbit links nine-year-old man
to his stepdaughters stabbing death this
is so crazy and I just I love when
technology is like used to solve crimes
and they said Fitbit was going under and
it's just getting started right like you
know I'm
Fitbit now because if I ever do go room
style like they'll have my information
but this is like you would think oh they
tracked the steps to find out where they
went
no investigators have charged an elderly
California man with killing with killing
his 67 year old stepdaughter was that
angry that late in life when I think of
stepdaughter like I don't think 67 years
no I think she's like 19 and a little
baby back [ __ ] brat when I skimmed this
story I assumed he was 67 killing his
stepdaughter but the stepdaughter says
he's what 90 please 90 he's 90 who's
that bitter that old don't you a hit
like over 65 and you're just like
whatever don't come over it no I'm 25
and I feel that way it's like agree to
disagree let's let it go right he's be
with you I'm gonna like I am Who I am I
can't change right I don't don't try to
change me I won't try to change you
right so he was charged after data from
her Fitbit along with surveillance
footage allegedly linked him to the
murder scene according to police reports
obtained by people and me Aiello 90 was
detained September 25th on a
first-degree murder charge
police allege in the report that Aiello
slashed and stabbed Karen navara his 92
year old wife's daughter on September
8th her remains were found in her San
Jose home on September 13th after
concerned relatives called police to
request a welfare check when police
arrived the kitchen knife that had been
used to cut her neck and head was found
protruding from one of Nevarez hands oh
yeah this is graphic let's get to the
Fitbit part the police report on the
murder alleges I yellow told
investigators he last owned a bar on
September 8th when he stopped by her
home to bring her food he told the Texas
he was inside Navarro's residence for no
more than 15 minutes the police report
indicates but police managed to recover
surveillance footage from the
neighborhood that said that they say
confirms I yellows car was parked in
Navarro's driveway for more than 20
minutes they also recovered data from
Nevarez Fitbit device the police report
indicates that information showed
numerous steps that showed navara the
stepdaughters heart rate spiked at
around 3:20 p.m. at the same time his
car can be seen in her driveway the data
also indicates her heart rate started to
slow eventually stopping at 3:28 p.m.
according to the police report I didn't
even think we were gonna link it through
the heart rate I thought it was gonna be
like she got a spike in
she's running around her kitchen island
like get away from me but did she make
him eat her daily goal is really the
moral of that story well she got her
heart rate up and then she didn't but
this is really like wild dark please but
really no no I guess so about getting my
steps in it's like it I became a crazy
what's your step goal ten thousand a day
oh I was like once counting steps and my
goal was actually only seven thousand a
day I only hit 10,000 a day if I'm at a
concert and I'm like dancing right doing
the shuffle right and then I'm like
stepping the whole time uh and I check
my steps on my phone I don't know I
don't wear a Fitbit or anything but I
like to see on my phone like where I'm
at but there are some days where the JIT
don't even like on a Sunday hungover
like oh yeah you get in 45 steps it's
and it's like that's generous absolutely
and that's why I quit wearing it on the
weekends because it would stress I don't
even have it on today and I should wear
it around New York cuz you know I'm
getting my steps in but you know that
your phone counts your steps to in your
health hat can I tell you some and it
doesn't register actively like I could
you I could show you though and you can
like tell me a day where you walk a lot
I could tell you how many steps okay I
need you to know the other day I heard a
weird noise coming from my phone and I
put it up to my ear and it sounded like
like static and I was like they're
listening
I was literally taking a nap and I was
like but they like the NSA tapped into
my phone they turned it on and they were
trying to record me so I just sorted
saying crazy [ __ ] they were literally
recording me yeah and be like if you're
listening like I'm out of toilet paper
yeah if you're listening send Doritos
and what are we gonna do about Britney
you know I mean right yeah tap into
Britney's phone yeah I'm always like on
YouTube like if somebody were to look at
my YouTube it's like Illuminati like
what you know all just crazy stuff cuz I
like to investigate I'm the conspiracy
theorist like as much as the rest of the
world actually only like based in
reality conspiracies in total just like
things you don't want to believe to be
true right but like I've never really
doubled into the elite Illuminati it's
kind of started off as a joke and right
it's more like I was investigating like
how JFK died but you got it a man like
there's some sort of like good old boys
club also why is nobody asked me to join
I thrive in like group settings right
you would bring so much like pizzazz to
the group I feel I could plan like our
little like cocktail hours right maybe
you want to talk about world domination
like a social event
coordinator thanks my social chair thank
you it's like a bunch of old white men
and then there's just like me being like
who wants pigs in a blanket and martinis
me me I pick something like it's my
favorite food there's nothing better
there's truly nothing better cuz it's
like be even better than hot dog because
you're having more bread to dog ratio
and the bread is better it's like a
croissant it doesn't get better than a
croissant
I like the multi-faceted layers like I
wasn't into the cronut because I just
wasn't into the cronut but a regular
flaky or like chocolate croissant
bye see ya blackout dead right it
doesn't need to be that complicated
you know the simpler the better Krispy
Kreme you know Dominique Ansel like I
don't need a car net well when the hot
signs on the way Krispy Kreme it's a
very southern thing like I'll roll up oh
no totally even only got three Yorkers I
can know about it and like when I'm in
Florida like we stopped by when you're
in Florida forgot to check I fit in your
prison my mats all after I take a
relaxing baths all right yes yeah okay
next story speaking of potential bath
salts The OC star Mischa Barton joins
the cast of the hills a reboot this made
me sad I saw this this makes me say well
this made me like puzzled and then I saw
a video that made me sad downside okay
Mischa Barton is returning to the small
screen and making her reality TV debut a
source confirms to people that the
actress has joined the cast of the hills
reboot MTV later confirmed the news too
though she never appeared on the
original series which aired for six
seasons from 2006 to 2010 Barton has a
special connection to the MTV show at 17
she was catapulted to fame for her
starring role as Marissa Cooper on Fox's
The OC which premiered in 2003 and
became a cult phenomenon almost
overnight The OC inspired MTV's Laguna
Beach the real Orange County which
eventually spun off into the hills so
she this would be like teri hatcher
going on unreal housewives a hundred
full circle and for that I am very meta
right very meta and I am here for that
aspect of it and it's like really the
hills became the OC like life imitates
art so the OC I never watched a single
episode I was like two years older than
it and I didn't even really watch the
hills or look gonna Beach I'm 31 I was
32 so I missed it by like a years
tastehh I am I really an arbiter of
taste I'm that's gonna go on my grave
yes you know a dense [ __ ] arbiter of
taste so Mishka oh sweet sweet sweet
Mishka
hey I'm saying her name right Nisha Oh
Misha Mishka who needs borscht okay
Misha Misha Misha Misha captain I
wouldn't be his eyes if her full name is
Misha and then like at Ellis Island they
changed it you know and I'd like her
real last name is not Barton it's like
Bruno Misha Bruno you know what I mean
and then she's like Oh dad can we change
it to Barton you know like anything yeah
I mean here's the I never was she good
on the show
yes well here's the problem with Mischa
Barton she was amazing actually I'm sure
if I watch it do see back the enemy
Marissa Cooper like would piss me off
cuz she makes poor choices right she
doesn't appreciate the things that she
has in life she's always complaining she
thinks her parents are out to get her
when really all they want to do was to
provide for her her little sister's
horse has alopecia and she just has no
sympathy with her little sister's horse
her little sister played by shailene
Woodley's horse had alopecia and it was
like a great travesty and family wait
huh
what do you mean shailene Woodley's
horse shailene Woodley's horse who they
spent like a fortune on then turned out
to have alopecia and like she could no
longer compete with her but I don't know
what just happened or what was just said
but my mom I got to go back to watch
Marilyn so like Marissa Cooper clearly
deals with a lot and her dad Jimmy
Cooper is like the birdie made off of
their town their mom is like the village
[ __ ] but I love her and like she's just
trying to provide for her family and
like Marissa get off her jock yeah
anyway so I don't know if I would like
Marissa Cooper anymore but then her
gravest error was when the show was at
its height
Mishka decided she was too good for it
killed off her character and the show
was never the same
I'm at this point I'm so humble in my
career if like you know like if a show
once it's locked man for 45 years
I'll do it the dream job security job
security do you know that people like
don't have jobs my ears are so hot could
you ever
one day it's the girl maybe the the
actress who I sat next to on the plane
if it was a toaster she sounds like our
demo and she really is she's the age
group like it's perfect
she's probably watching him like
freaking freaking and tweaking and
tweaking enjoying with firm all the
stress Jules could you imagine being on
a show that is so so popular like
changes you know the landscape really
speaks to the culture of the time and
like not wanting to be associated with
it anymore and like not wanting to talk
about it and interviews like if you had
been on One Tree Hill and then you're
like ashamed like how could you how dare
you people get too big for their
britches like I will never be too big
for like Atlanta Georgia
those are my roots I will never be too
big for the University of Mississippi I
am waiting for them to ask me to do the
commencement speech they haven't yet
that is such a good like goal in life
thank you to be like the notable alumni
mere University and they actually called
me the Alumni Department called me two
days ago and they were like looking for
a donation and I said Brianna if you're
watching I talked to her on the phone
and I was like Brianna let me tell you
something right now like I am NOT in the
position right now to give you money but
when I do it will be such a large
donation that you name the food hall
after me I don't want the theater
building to be named after me I want the
place where people come together and eat
snacks to be named after me the student
union the Heather McMahon Hall of snacks
University of Mississippi it has a nice
ring to it doesn't it The Blind Side of
course you did of course I did yeah I'm
did you appreciate the portrayal
absolutely and I know the two E's so
yeah
Collins chewy is I think she's my year
and she was a Katy and I was at Delta
Gamma so we were like the cheer like the
Lily Collins yes oh my god how was she
she was the loveliest think you know
nice um I I didn't know Michael like
personally but everybody knew him on
campus and lovely lovely family I
thought it was amazing movie I did the
little boy s J really got to run onto
the field I don't remember her cuz I he
was drunk and I never made into a game
oh my god I did make it to a game but
liking this out like we like do tail get
to another level right not like like I'd
never wear a t-shirt to a game I would
be in a full mosquito outfit with like
pearls and like like a full thing
totally so it's more about like the
ambiance and like camaraderie and like
drinking bourbon and eating pimento
cheese it's not about like my color yeah
yeah but you know love him like at the
time when it was happening like before
it was a movie do you know of the story
Michael or was he a big get for the
school he was just like a whether they
deal for the school but again like I
don't even know really like how football
is scored and I'm like I don't know it's
scored it also I just like you know I'm
like oh hey great yes yes well wow what
an interesting factoid I'm glad I and
I'm sure everybody at Ole Miss is gonna
be mad that I said that that I don't
know about sports but honestly like
don't know and it's like you know a lot
about the things that you know about it
you can't you can't know everything
unless you're Elon Musk
thank you you know like you were like
wise beyond your years you really are
like I get a really good positive energy
from you and I just feel like you're
like on another wavelength oh my good
think you I feel the same way about you
I feel like I also say these like isms
that like are very old like old soul
100% I am me honestly and truly like an
84 year old Jewish lady like in this
body me too you know with heart with our
cigarettes and our glass of cab sitting
somewhere in Queens just talking [ __ ]
that would be so fun that would make her
a funny show oh my god what's so crazy
and I'm still shook by this is when you
came on the show last time and you were
talking about like a random show that I
had never heard about yeah and you were
like if I put it out into the universe
like maybe they'll maybe it'll reboot
what's he called
designing women' reboot literally this
is the craziest thing if you're just
watching for the first time last time I
was here I said my dream is that they're
doing a designing women' reboot which
was this very famous show with Annie
Potts gene smart Delta Burke and Dixie
Carter that's here your dream role would
be for them to bring that show back and
for you to be on it two days later after
I left the toast because we put it out
into the universe ABC announced that
they picked it up that is so [ __ ]
weird I never I still do I never heard
of that show like that is so random
can't find it on Hulu you have to go
watch it on YouTube but it is an
incredible show it was like it was in
the same like lane is like Murphy Brown
but it was a show about for interior
designers in Atlanta and they really
like were pioneers for political
conversations empowering women talking
about like gay rights like it was a show
that made everything that's taboo in the
south they really like brought it to a
head and discuss it and it was insanely
like witty and funny and then literally
two days later they announced it and I
called my manager I was sitting on a
tarmac for three hours at JFK and I was
like this is happening like it like to
happen you're always at the airport or
on the plane I'm always on a plane
Thanks and that is why I have such good
plane etiquette if you ever see me in
the airport you will see that I'm not
acting a fool I may be drunk but I
literally like I'm like I'm just a savvy
traveler ya know like you know like you
have your space right and it's yours and
you can do what you want within it but
you don't like lean on to the I have a
couple like absolutely no nose at the
airport there are too many men wearing
open-toed sandals okay it is different
if you're a woman you're coming from
Barbados if you're a grown-ass man wear
a decent excuse me [ __ ] shoe okay
we're a sensible clothes chokes you okay
do not put your feet up on the business
of the person in front of you either
that is disgusting either no no other no
no if you're in zone 6 we all know that
you bought your flight on orbit okay you
did not you don't have miles you don't
have perks so do not stop your feet
Michael when they're like we have to
check your bag at the gate guess what
you're not on the front of the airplane
all right and I was in zone 2 yesterday
and I could already see there like any
we have a full flight because every
flight is full so just know that there
every airliner over sells flights so
this gentleman I was walking in on zone
2 I was like great I just made the
cutoff because literally by half as a
two and a half they were checking back
right this man wanted to cause a scene
and I lose this close to turning around
I mean like you need to settle down
you're a grown-ass man quit acting like
a baby
it's free it's gonna get there right you
will maybe have to wait what an extra
seven minutes like I can't oh my god I'm
a my third is I'm always always no
matter what you say thank you to the
pilot and all the crew when you get off
that airplane they got you there safely
and you need to be respectful to the
stewardess totally are the stewards men
I don't know what the proper term is
steward a steward but the stewards the
stewards or actually is that an archaic
word what's the what's the term white
attendants Oh perhaps oh oh no all my
flight attendant friends will you let
send me a message and let me know if I'm
using like you know you don't say
waitress anymore its server oh I didn't
know that yeah I mean I worked you know
as a server
what about actress is that offensive I
am an actress I have a vagina what
they're like oh you she's an actor I
don't care I'm an actress I've got a
large gaping vagina I love saying that
sometimes I mean sometimes it's what the
moment calls for
how do you know about the way people
dress in airports like what is your take
on what people should be wearing there
was a big thing I think was a United
flight that a girl wasn't allowed to get
on because she had tights
she was Mary yeah like she's wearing
leggings but apparently there she wasn't
wearing pants and technically like my
outfit today like they might actually
I'm wearing shorts under my shirt but
like they might look at me like you're
not wearing pants
well also I would never wear shorts on a
flight just because that's see there
have been so many asses and that's the
only but the thing that that was
everybody was like up in arms about it I
think she was a airline employee and she
was trying to catch a flight and they
were like you needed dress size I always
try and bring the sensible blazer just a
nice jacket I was wearing like a sneaker
a close toed shoe I just like to put my
best foot forward any more makeup um I
do wear makeup and if I don't wear
makeup I have my nice Panama hat on and
like a pair of sunglasses so I look like
I'm great I'm glamorous yeah and I will
tell you this right now do you want to
get into any of the sky lounges as long
as you have a blazer on from the top up
they cannot see you sitting at the desk
what you're wearing when you roll in you
will get upgraded you will get VIP
service if you just look like a decent
human being
so don't roll on the flight in your
pajamas never why I never get upgraded I
actually for someone who dresses for
every everything I don't dress up to fly
because of like the conditions of flying
right like I need to be wearing like
harem pants so that my legs can fit into
this little box like and I don't wear
makeup anymore just because my outfit
doesn't require me you can make harem
pants look nice you didn't go to that
you know I mean for me it's like the
makeup really makes a difference like if
I made up like I look wonderful when I'm
not made up they asked me how old I am
before I go through the new scanning
machines because you have to be 13 or
above really yeah yeah always ask me
they're like art ma'am where are your
children everyone just like suspects
that I have six kids because that means
because II think you'd be a great mom
you know or because I'm tired and
sweating all the time a hormonal
imbalance I'm talking to my doctor about
it thank you for your concern I'm glad
to hear it well speaking of Airlines
another great segue because a big Bazaar
Egypt air sorry why are we flying to
Egypt aren't they in turmoil right now I
believe so but you know the pyramids are
there and it's but there is a lot a lot
of [ __ ] to say yeah
a bizarre Egypt air Drew Barrymore
interview battles the Internet's not
know you were going into a your
Barrymore interview on
as a source blames the translation so
someone on an EgyptAir flight caught an
interview with Egypt airs version of Sky
mag and Drew Barrymore
and like they actually decided to read
it and it was very troubling it says
quote despite being unstable in her
relationships most of her life
despite the six several unsex
unsuccessful marriages and despite the
busy life of stardom that dominated her
life for several years the beautiful
American Hollywood actress drew
Barrymore has recently decided to
temporary sick take an unlimited
vacation to play her most crucial role
as a mother while many people were
offended at the statements in the
article a source close to the actress
tells people it is just a case of things
getting lost in translation quote this
is truly an innocent translation job
that somehow made it through the
channels also she's been very open about
her failed marriages and like how she's
like kind of did a conscious uncoupling
with her now X like I feel like Drew
Barrymore is like such an open book
she's always been like her kid olive and
is it like junebug all of them all of it
know that Alvin June's a nail place
isn't it or do it's a restaurant
Alvin Oh thinking I'll figure it off but
then like I love him Betts is a clothing
store I love all the meds
yes so I know I think one of her kids
I'll live in Frankie Frankie I was close
June Frankie Frankie and June you see
that's what that's why I connect I feel
like she's always been open about like
she did cocaine at like 11 that's so
crazy why are we acting like this is a
crazy thing for her to be honest and
open about her life right I guess just
the way that they portrayed it it was
like making her it was just not a
respectful way to to discuss it like
despite least this this isn't like she's
America's Sweetheart like you don't talk
about our girl like that that is so true
but that's probably why I wouldn't do an
interview for Egypt airline you know new
Mac I also like our times tough egyptair
yeah are they paying you for it probably
oh my god those airlines have so much
money or where she's just like leaving
Morocco and like somebody asked her a
question like you know like if she was
like excuse me yeah I'm taking care of
my children
right like you she reaches a failed she
yeah I know I know [ __ ] that's why
I'm here by myself you know like I think
that that's how it went down
no totally we need more context around
this story yeah it's just like I'm not
true she's no
who actually opens those magazines I
know and that's another thing don't
touch those magazines cuz they have a
lot of germs and I'm not a germaphobe
but we all know although I love shopping
in SkyMall but you can do it online
right know I'm a germaphobe for sure but
an airplane germs are the worst kinds of
germs yeah so don't touch the magazines
don't trust touch the throw-up bag
everyone puts their gum in including
myself actually I really think I'd be an
awesome mother because when I was flying
to Europe last year there was a little
kid in front of me and it was like my
maternal instincts just set in we had
just landed and the mother I could tell
she had two kids who's looking around
panic and I just knew the kid was about
to throw up and Jeff had no idea why I
was like searching through the bags and
I threw it throw it bag over my seat in
front of me and she was like thank you
and Jeff was like how did you know what
was about to happen it was like
something inside me told me that this
whole three-year-old was about to puke
and she like was in tears and was like
thank you and was like I just knew I
don't like goddamn maternal instinct God
spoke to me Wow so anyway so you do have
it yeah I hope yeah yeah well since we
have you here I need an update i'm
brittany 9-1-1 because last time you
were here like it was taking the world
by storm
everyone now really the whole universe
is aware about it of brittany 9-1-1 and
it's like even enews with their
Instagram captions where they never want
to end people like they know something's
out they do she's been posting some
interesting stuff recently actually do
you mind if I open my Instagram and we
discuss some of the things I would like
that a real like DBQ yes so she posted a
few things from Paris like a couple
weeks post her being being in Paris and
they were the most random photos but one
of the photos that she post said she was
like oh look at this really cool street
art above she's like I saw this really
cool street art above a woman's head
which that makes no sense and it was a
evil eye and you're telling me that she
isn't being attacked by the Illuminati
looking right in the camera or it's like
maybe a room situation yeah it could be
here I'll pull up the photo just so you
see it interesting yeah she's been she's
literally been just sending his messages
wait did she take it down that's another
message wait she took down the photo of
pear her in Paris that's another message
we were supposed to discuss
because I was supposed to discover this
she realized that the universe just sent
this to us
right she took it down I bet the
Illuminati contacted her and they're
like you're you're giving off too many
sign exactly Wow
and then she posted this the other day
if she doesn't scare the hell out of you
a little she's not the one so maybe
she's like been like looming over Sam's
right that's a weird boat also Jeff
honestly would be like yeah you scare
the hell out of me
yeah as it should be know for sure but
who is she referring to like who's yeah
who I don't know clearly she's scaring
everyone maybe Sam was like you're back
on the cocaine heat maybe he's nervous
yeah here's the thing people have really
been sending me messages like Britney
and I'm online you have to save her I
feel like my hands are tied at this
moment I am doing what I can but until
somebody from her camp or somebody who
actually has like the key to like
Louisiana I can't get it no and I feel
like you've already done so much for her
by by really by bringing attention to
the issue and saying the things that no
one that everyone was too scared to say
yeah we were we were really all thinking
it so you've she should be thanking you
and it a certain point like it is out of
your hands in it that's where we're at
now so I look forward to seeing like
what becomes like is she gonna put out
new music like what is she doing I don't
know I don't think Josh you might put
out new music but really my biggest
concern like Britney is there and I need
to save her but who really need to save
is Lindsay oh my god did you see that
video did I see the video of her trying
to steal refugees yes I saw the video
that was so crazy we talked about it
yesterday I don't even know how this
week has got me talking about it Monday
on the show yes and I knew all had very
valid points right but I just think the
level of cocaine that she's on is just a
new thing that she's on cocaine is
cocaine yes and that's cocaine yes
cocaine and that would and that a side
effect of that would be kidnapping
refugee children well it's just because
you get that superhuman strength or
you're like oh I'm gonna do the most in
the least at the same time I mean okay
but what was most alarming is the video
of her in the bathroom when she's
clearly like crossfaded you know what I
mean she was like okay I don't see
everything that she posts because like I
can't like I don't there's people
talking outside the door dude yo can we
just open the door and tell them that
we're young Oh
we are shooting a show of course the
minute we open the door they walk away
well good I'm glad we opened it then
yeah because I don't even know if you
could hear them but they're just in my
mind
yeah they what it was like it's like
Lindsey is more important than your
conversation and saving her I agree I
think she's in a worse off spot than
anyone else is right now
did you she's trying to like make the
best of it she is but did you they
better leave me teacher I'm like oh wait
yeah no your fight your fight okay so
what the video of her in the bathroom
looking for her she was trying to say
earpods
but she said no sir I ate your buds but
she said like ear um [ __ ] what did she
say she said something that didn't make
sense then she had her friend who I
guess was Greek or Persian or something
he was in the bathroom with her and he's
like turn the phone around show them my
thighs show them up buzz
that's literally he was screaming like I
have been enough around enough people on
cocaine to know that this guy was out of
his mind
and so he's geeking out in the mirror
it's like Sharma 500 but literally the
noise he made afterwards and Lindsey's
trying to turn her phone around so she
could show everyone his face you know
it's like when you're on uppers you get
that superhuman strength
it just looks anything where does she
live you know like what is her home look
like I just dina Lohan just filed for
bankruptcy 1.8 million dollars in the
hole oh my goodness yeah oh my god
speaking of Lindsay Lohan and I was
meant to say this we were talking bout
actors who like don't appreciate like
you know the things that made them a big
star we're having an opposite problem
like that with the man who played Aaron
Samuels who's like going around thirsty
everywhere like doing October 3rd like
impersonation oh I know he yeah like
he's like super thirsty and I mean on
the one hand like I appreciate like that
you love that we love your movie like
yeah it is getting a little desperate
you know who's the loveliest person I've
ever met in my life who's from Mean
Girls Lacey Chabert oh my god well I
love her because she's a hallmark
actress and I if I was gonna say she was
she's one of the best ones because she's
a great actress she's so pretty and like
just cute and enjoyable to watch we went
to lunch together in LA cuz we had a
mutual friend and I'm not even gonna lie
she was the nicest person ever and I
really think we need to promote all of
her hallmark movies she's a phenomenal
actress and a good soul
no and I love that she does hallmark
movies
it is the number one watched television
channel during the Christmas season like
her movies are being watched more than
like some indie movie in the freaking
cinema club and nobody gives Hallmark
Channel the credit they deserved they go
to Africa and shoot movies they have
like big budge like she just did a movie
in Africa oh my god that's so cool yeah
we got to get her on this show because
like I gotta get the tips to becoming a
Hamar secretary that's like I just left
a SoulCycle class can I just take this
off stick my straw in here although I
don't know if it'll reach and then you
gotta like tilt it back okay I'm going
over to Instagram because we have so
many questions for you and I would be
remiss oh my god people are calling me
like I can't and I shan't um okay a lot
of Microsoft a lot of question about
fuzz sorry that's the police like I did
Sean my boss it's my favorite thing to
say now no that's amazing and that maybe
I should follow her we have a question
who are you more worried about Lindsay
or Britney Lindsay I'm Way more worried
about Lindsay I think Britney has enough
people protecting her that I think we
can save Britney but Lindsay I think is
he's a gonner what do you think about
amanda Bynes
I think Amanda Bynes it's gonna make a
comeback
I'm so ready for it I just watched
Sydney white last week and like that
wasn't even her best work and it was
still so good but I think what's gonna
happen is when she makes a comeback
there's she's gonna do a tell-all and I
think we're gonna learn a lot of
information a lot of information that I
don't think anybody's ready for because
I think Amanda knows things
she knows the things that we know that
you know that we know that and he knows
and that we've alluded to on the show
but there are still some big names that
haven't been taken down yet and I think
just because they resign from
Nickelodeon that it's over but it hasn't
even begun oh yeah look at my feet I see
you um what are your thoughts on Lindsay
Lohan's new strange accent
Madonna vibes Meghan Marco vibes again I
often times when I've had like two
chardonnays
I like love to go into different accents
you know sometimes I've talked like this
you know sometimes I'm Russian sometimes
like what I love doing Australian you
know I and sorry that's a natural thing
for me to like change accents so clearly
she's you know consuming things so I
just think it's par for the course
got it and what do you thing about Megan
Merkel's new
British accent okay here's the deal if
you live in England you're gonna be
British
it doesn't matter like when I go to the
South when I'm in Mississippi I kind of
talk country when I'm up here like I
literally get a Long Island accent I
just think maybe it's like I'm slightly
schizophrenic I'm not quite sure but I
think okay Megan you're royalty if you
want to talk with a British accent
you're a queen no totally and now that
at first like I was gonna throw shade
because it's like she's just trying to
be something like she's not but the more
I think about it it's like I watched one
episode of shits Creek and all of a
sudden I'm away were rose yes you know
like if I moved to Britain and not only
just was a peasant there but like I
represented like the whole royal family
I would start to say family like family
all of a sudden I'm British
right so and I feel like yeah even when
you hang out with people you start to
talk like that like when you go to camp
and you come home talking like your kin
friends all of your camp friends but the
thing with Lindsay is is you know
especially in the video and choose
trying to say the refugees when she was
like trying to speak Arabic and Russian
but it's kind of like only trying to
live Lindsay Zack
Lindsay's accents kind of like here like
I don't even know where it goes right
it's like he'll I feel like she should
just try to be like a citizen of the
world like she's making up her own acts
she really is but and then when she goes
to Greece it's just like just no holds
bar like just buckle up we don't know
what's gonna she needs to get a Greek
accent she'd and then she can roll in My
Big Fat Greek Wedding three and then
what I'll come full circle there we go
loves it um something I meant to ask you
about because you're a friend of Busy
Philipps
I am and Claudia and I were talking
about her new show that finally has a
name and a tag line busy tonight and a
premiere date and like a format I get
from what I understand yes um and do you
have any additional details about about
the show and the format um I don't
actually they've kept everything pretty
hush-hush and my best friend Raymond is
her personal assistant but no I think
the show's gonna be amazing
Kelly Oxford's one of her had writers
like I think it's gonna be great I I
don't know anything about the show yet
but she did announce on her first crest
I believe it's gonna be Julia Roberts so
I mean that's gonna be dramatic unless I
yet I like her for sure I don't know I
don't know if I use the word dramatic
okay
discuss okay okay great that's cool I'll
check it out I feel like it to me like
Chelsea Handler vibes with like a little
Andy Cohen just like late-night fun yes
and I mean everyone's asking me if I'm
gonna be on the show she hasn't asked
yeah busy I love
be on your show but she hasn't asked me
yet you'd be great I mean maybe I'll be
like warna maybe she'll bring on like
people off the street guess you know
like and then nobody knows who you are
cuz I'm not famous and then I'm just
like what's good I'm not busy at the gym
holler we're friends you know
got it yeah well I look forward to it
it's gonna the show's gonna be great I
think it's gonna be a huge success and I
think we need that real Girl Talk I
think it's gonna be like real female
friend yeah because I mean there are no
women in late-night right now right
and she's not a stand-up so I don't
think it's gonna be roasting people the
way handler was I think it's gonna be
more like we're sitting down in a comfy
space really talking about real [ __ ]
toast sounds like a show I know right um
we had a question for you do you or
would you ever do stand-up
I do do stand-up I do do it yeah I do do
it yes and I'm gonna I'm actually
writing one-woman show so I'm gonna take
it on the road hopefully so don't worry
I'm back in action I get a little burnt
out this summer but we are back putting
on our creative wigs and like we're
gonna do the most this fun that's gonna
be live in cold months I really do
oh I feel the exact same way it's like
I'm even like thinner in the winter then
I am in the summer and I am so much
thinner right it's just cuz like the
pressures off and it's like and everyone
else is looking worse and that makes me
look even better and I'm one of those
people like after say like I stole
psycho class you were discussing this
the other day like I'm like you I'm beet
red and I sweat for four hours after so
in the winter it's so great when you can
like shower put yourself together and
feel like a human I'm way more
productive right and you like walk out
and it's like thirty degrees and it's
like refreshing I love it I I do I love
it as long as I can get away in March
and let go to the Turks and Caicos I'm
fine I don't mind wearing a nice like
crisp jacket totally I really put on a
persona when I come here I mean I'm
always sassy but what I feel like when
we vibe and we talk like I get very
crisp no crisp like I get so Moyer on
the show like and I wouldn't have it any
other way like I were just talking about
shits Creek yeah I just caught up on
season four so it's top of mind and I
mean I love Alexis and Ted I don't feel
like that's a popular opinion people who
know about shits Creek are all like oh
it's the best show ever
yeah but I'm also upset that Showtime
just cancelled my favorite show I'm
dying what's here what's it called it's
a called I'm dying up here oh really
he's so good watch it it's on Showtime
honey season um they did two seasons
just cancel that it's hard to like watch
a show knowing like that it didn't get
another season like I literally had
Nikita wants to Jeff and he was like
almost into your zone on the way here oh
my god you think this is [ __ ] I was
like let's go to the Showtime office and
let them know we're like to start a
petition change.org yeah that's great um
we approached about your relationship
how do you guys make like long distance
work for you okay I say this all the
time it we knew we were gonna be a long
distance forever but long distance for
some people just works here's the thing
we've been together seven years would be
eight in February he is very
career-driven so um I and we just fly
back and forth all the time and they get
a bunch of miles but I'm like
long-distance like I still am like crazy
wild head over heels about Jeff and
we've been seven years we never took a
break like there were no ups and downs
we've been like madly googoo gaga and
love all that time but we've been very
selfless and like he's like I know you
have to go to LA and do your things and
like we've been just building the Empire
together and he's an engineer he's an
engineer do you think okay he's like you
cannot but it's great if you guys see
the Italian stallion out be like Jeff
the engineer he is over all of his
friends were teasing him about it but
another reason why I love long-distance
is like because the sex is still like
really good and like we're still like
really passionate about each other but
then I get to like send his ass on a
plane like not pick up after him
I'm not putting [ __ ] in the crock-pot
like I'm not a homemaker I'm kind of
playing with clothes - cheese thank you
yes
Oh Jeff dresses so sharp yes he always
has a sports coat on you know yeah I
don't know what a sports coat is but I
love the sound of it like it's a
southern thing it sounds like a very
useful thing it's just like a really
nice blazer like it would be in like a
nice navy it's kind of lightweight I
mean it's essentially like a blazer but
it's just a real crisp blazer and he
usually wears it with like a white
button-down and like just cool jeans and
like converse you know what I mean or
he'll wear like a nice red wing
steel-toed boot cuz he's an engineer
right um how do you come up with all of
your characters like what is your
inspiration from them for them like
Brenda Carlyle well Brenda Carlisle was
created in actually saw the gold jacket
at Goodwill and I just like it clicked
because it was kind of loosely based off
some of my sorority sisters
some Mississippi like I was such a fish
out of water in Mississippi but it was
the greatest four years of my life so
it's just like I had a friend's mom and
she would show up like dripped head to
toe and chanel it'd be the middle of
August we'd be like at a sorority
function and she would just be like I've
the full like wool chanel there's so
much money in Mississippi people don't
even realize and so she was just like
crazy and everyone in Mississippi drinks
bourbon and you know like in the South
if you're in a sorority one of the rules
was if you wanted to smoke a cigarette
you had to be seated you couldn't be
standing up while you smoke this is kind
of that we're like yeah we're there's
like rules we're like we keep it classy
but we also are like you know kind of
sloppy yeah totally
oh my god I didn't know the rule that
that was a thing oh it's a rule across
the board ask any any sorority probably
in the south we had to sit down and if
they didn't have that rule then maybe
they weren't the good one I can't
imagine you being in a sorority like now
I thrived and you know what everybody
has this opinion of sororities like it
was a bunch of Mean Girls we had such
camaraderie everyone we did so many
philanthropic things I loved my sister
like I have only positive experiences
with sardis cuz I went to a small school
and I feel like I didn't have like the
actual sorority experience but if I
thought about like sororities at like
mmm in Mississippi like that it sounds
scary no it was great also I don't know
how they let me in I was at Delta Gamma
anchor up sisters we were founded at the
University of Mississippi I mean it was
very overwhelming for me but I was
pledge class president and then I was
was I was bid day chair wow I like did
the most totally but I did I was a
little bit of a black sheep because our
first swap are like social which is the
party that you do with you know a
fraternity
the theme was hell's our bikers and
babes
each was Hells Angels themed but I heard
bikers and dressed up like Lance
Armstrong so I got I got on the bus to
go and I was full head-to-toe spandex
with like LIVESTRONG bracelets and
people were like all dress and like cute
like leather gear and I was totally
misread it so when it comes to
characters I've always liked thought
outside the box
got outside the box so for ever I always
had to wear spandex to every swap even
if it was like belle of the ball things
yeah that's amazing yeah Wow well I
wonder if they have stir our teas in
business school because I don't know if
you know I'm applying to Harvard
Business School I did not know when this
is incredible I applied to Harvard
originally for undergrad
Danu my dad thought I could be
but they didn't accept me but I did go
to the Harvard of the South University
of Mississippi did you apply early um I
did I love that I always said like if I
didn't I applied early to Colgate cuz
like that was my reach but like if I
didn't have a school that I was new I
wanted to go do I was gonna just apply
early to Harvard because like why not
why not they probably get like so many
people who think like that I think you
really need to send in like like a whole
video kid yes you need a social media
like media kit and you need to just be
like this is who I am
I'm you already have a thriving business
with the morning toast right I feel like
a side so my biggest hurdle is gonna be
the GMAT and I'm taking a practice test
soon and that'll determine if I move
forward with this plan that started on
Monday because we reported a story that
business school applications are down
because the job market is very good
apparently right um and why why go to
business school if you're already an
entrepreneur or hustling right if you're
like have a job paying back those
student loans like why go into more debt
there you go so that leaves an opening
though for me um I'm gonna take a
practice GMAT if I get below a 500 I
will give up on the stream if I get a
500 or above like that what's it out of
its added 800 but that would be a good
starting point like without a tutor or
any like without even knowing anything
like if on my worst day right I could
get a 500 I'm gonna I'm gonna go for it
I actually ended up at the University of
Mississippi by accident because I had
applied to only two schools I applied to
Harvard for undergrad which was just
some real just like shot majority I
think that's my favorite events
Armstrong is a close second but that's
my favorite thing because that is always
like how I felt about early decision in
Harvard and like how you should approach
it you should just go for it like I mean
and then I applied to Pepperdine and I
literally thought I was gonna get into
Pepperdine and I took out a whole like
tour the school from basically their
president and I did I was like oh great
I got into Pepperdine two weeks before I
was supposed to graduate high school I
found that I got rejected from
Pepperdine not bitter about it still
bitter and I had two weeks literally two
weeks before school was over to figure
out where he's gonna go I visited the
University of Alabama it was the most
traumatic like 24 hours of my life and I
said well it looks like I'm going to Ole
Miss because Ole Miss and Alabama were
the only two schools that still had
rolling admission so when I showed up to
Ole Miss I showed up at orientation and
had never even visited and I just pulled
a Hail Mary I was like well I hear that
you know they got a great tailgate and
it's cool school and then I
showed up and it was God's country and I
never left and it was the best four
years of my life everything works out
the way it's supposed to I'm obsessed
with Pepperdine for multitude of reasons
one someone who works at Pepperdine law
school I don't know if that's a thing
just message me the other day she was
like I work in admissions at Pepperdine
law so like yeah if you want to speak to
her she's a toaster right and so she was
telling me about like the Business
School process and trying to get me to
come to Pepperdine it's a great business
school and I mean is it I mean I think
it's in California but it's like it's in
Hawaii it's in Malibu it's right off the
PCH it's gorgeous
and my favorite thing about it is that's
where they film Disney's Friends for
Change with the Jonas Brothers Selena
and Hannah Montana who have never been
in the same room together since I mean
maybe that's why they needed such a vast
campus so that like they could all have
space from each other right um I just
called send it on on and on one spark
can lead another it's a great great song
and it was doing good in the world so
I'm just here for Pepperdine I
understand your love for it um no I'm
still here for it and I realized you
know what sometimes like God send June's
into a different direction and had I not
gonna the University of Mississippi I
actually would have never met the
Italian stallion how did you guys meet
again because my best friend Christina
Thompkins who's on the national Broadway
tour of Santa music plug who does she
play she plays like all of them she's a
swing right now but that's the best
thing because that way you don't burn
out your voice oh cool no birthday ties
yes and she's on doing her second tour
but she loves like being able to play
all the different characters that's so
cool yes so she was in the same
situation as me she applied to like one
like super fancy art school and didn't
get in so she was from New York and we
met the first day in theater class and I
looked at her and I was like do you know
what state we're in she's like I didn't
even know where Mississippi was and then
we became best friends and so Jeff and
her grew up together oh my goodness yes
but honestly like I love Mississippi and
I would literally like be buried there
and like it's the it's the best and I
look forward to your commencement speech
I'm gonna thank you so much I'm thrilled
to do it it's gonna happen schedule is
wide open thank you for joining us thank
you for having me I have so much fun and
I just feel like you are just like
really changing the world and I think we
need to give you the credit and you just
are so poignant and like elegant and so
kind and I appreciate you having me on
thank you we appreciate you coming
you're changing the world with your
Instagram stories and your premium
content left right and center and your
mom on bumble I hope she matches with
Mario singer trying to make it HAP
yeah yeah um so just thank you for being
here we'll see you again soon and
especially once you move to New York and
Claudia's on tour like we could do this
all the time
absolutely and also thanks to the
toasters you guys are the best like nice
cheerleader there's a biggest share
there so like so high yet so kind and
it's like if they like you they love you
and they just make everyone like feel as
good as we do all the time and so thank
you for representing our show
yeah it's positively you guys we'd let
be very much we're still glad that we
made this happen where can everyone
follow you for more premium content just
Heather K McMahon at Instagram love it
we will see you back here tomorrow I'll
be co-hosting with my sister Olivia and
we will get all the engagement details
we'll be taking all of your questions
and it's just gonna be a fun day right
now I have a headache so I need to
massage it out yes bye guys bye
you